people always ask how cold to make the
ice bath or the cold water or the shower
you want it to be uncomfortably cold
meaning you want to feel like i really
want to get out but you can safely stay
in and that's going to vary by person
and experience with it experience yeah
with the sauna it's the same thing
how hot to make it well don't kill
yourself obviously
be smart if you're pregnant you
shouldn't be doing this anyway um
but
it's very clear that what you need is
the release of something called
dinorphin we have endorphin which makes
us feel good it binds to these mu opioid
receptors in the body you have dinorphin
which is the terrible feeling that you
get when you're in really hot
temperatures it's also the terrible
effect that alcoholics feel when they
are in withdrawal
you feel agitated you want to get out
it's really unpleasant it's dinorphin
binding to the so-called kappa opioid
receptor is that's what you're trying to
trigger when you do that a number of
things happen you set off heat shock
proteins that go repair broken proteins
and misfolded proteins
it also makes it so that later endorphin
binds its receptor more strongly so when
you have this uncomfortable experience
in the heat you literally feel better in
real life when pleasurable vents come on
when you experience them in the same way
i like to say this that when you get
into a cold ice bath or cold shower the
increase in
epinephrine and dopamine
is
two to three hundred percent these are
huge increases and they last many hours
this is shown
because lately i've gotten a little bit
of pushback on
twitter that which is you know um
interesting place
people say well that's just in mice no
all the studies i just referred to are
all done in humans men and women fairly
broad age ranges so you want to be
uncomfortable in the cold you want to be
uncomfortable in the heat this is why
i'm not a big fan of infrared saunas
because they only go up to about 160 170
degrees
infrared light and far red light of all
kinds has been shown to be beneficial
for wound healing acne skin eyes they're
even guys now putting on their testicles
because it can increase testosterone and
sperm production yeah hormone release
hormone release but
in terms of the sauna you want that
strong heat stimulus yeah and that's
when you get crawl up to the 200 mark
and so on
you